you're CR I mean I've never heard anyone
say don't marry a a non-virgin at least
like at any church yeah like in this day
and age that's not so much a church
thing as much as that is like this is
something people won't say one thing we
do believe in is repentance and that a
person can restore themselves with the
help of Christ God can restore people if
you cooperate with him but
I I would add one detail which is that
it doesn't say like men stay a virgin
women sleep around and then get married
it tells everyone to remain a virgin and
it will also tell women by the way that
like the man you're with uh he might
have slept around he might like have had
struggles with a porn addiction I
struggle with it the issue is real the
issue is though like women have so much
more like like obviously power on the
sexual market like there's so much more
opportunity to do it from a young age
right so you're going to have women that
have slept around and men that are a bit
naive and they don't know how to like
like if you have a guy that's a virgin
and a woman that slept with I don't know
like however many people right he's
going to be naive and he won't really be
able to pick up on like certain red
flags I think